in our first book Freakonomics we wrote
about the economics of a crack selling
gang in Chicago and it was really fun
and interesting because we have these
assumptions if you sell drugs you become
a millionaire and it turns out that the
average criminal drug selling gang is
set up kind of like a franchise kind of
like a McDonald's really and that if you
own ten McDonald's you do pretty well
you make good money and if you're a
manager at one you do okay but if you're
an employee at one you don't you make
very little money and it turns out
that's the way a drug gang works that
the vast majority of the profits are
concentrated at the top and so we made
the argument that you know the average
crack dealer isn't you know they're not
very well off and you know the average
crack dealer lives at home with mom and
often has a second job at a place like
McDonald's well if crack dealers could
take lessons from their legitimate drug
selling counterparts they could do a lot
better so here's what I mean by that
generic drugs we think most people seem
to think because they're generic they're
priced the same that seems to be kind of
the way we think it should work because
it turns out if you look at the pricing
data on generic drugs across different
companies retailers that sell it there
are instances where I could go to a
Walgreens and buy a bottle of you know
pills generic let's say a statin and it
would cost about a hundred and ten
dollars and the same exact bottle of
pills at a different place like a Sam's
Club or Costco would cost literally
about ten or fifteen dollars so a markup
of like a thousand percent for the same
product that is sold by two companies
that look pretty similar and that are
generic moreover so when you look at
this data it's just shocking you think
how can this possibly be not only how
can they get away with it I mean they
anybody can charge anything they want
nobody has to buy it but why would
people buy it and it turns out the
reason is very simply that most people
who get
they're by their prescriptions in a
given place especially a lot of older
people who get you get more drugs as you
buy more drugs as you get older and
you're more on a kind of plan um you
just cut they just kind of make the
assumption that a generic pill is gonna
be priced the same from one to the next
but it turns out there's massive massive
disparity in that so really you know
Walgreens is way better at dealing drugs
then drug dealers are if the if the goal
is is profit maximizing and I think that
even though the people who are just
selling at the counter at Walgreens they
are I'm sure not making very much money
you know the shareholders shareholders
of Walgreens appreciate that a firm like
Walgreens is really good at dealing
drugs and profit maximizing so from an
economic perspective you have to applaud
them from a fairness perspective you
have to decry them on the other hand
that's what capitalism is about it's
about you know caveat emptor you are
free to shop around and if someone can
take advantage of what's called
information asymmetry right people not
people on different sides of a
transaction I know a lot more about this
price and you do they can exploit it
that's what's good about the digital
revolution is it makes information
asymmetry much harder to maintain so I
don't know if such an app exists but a
good one would be a very very very very
simple price comparison for generics for
generic drugs and it would presumably
off the bat save you know elderly
Medicare patients you know billions of
dollars within a month of course it
would cut into the the corporate profits
of of those shareholders but that's that
would work
you